in the last video we showed or we proved
to ourselves that the derivative of the
inverse sine of X is equal to 1 over the
square root of 1 minus x squared what I
encourage you to in this video is
deposit and try to do the same type of
proof for the derivative of the inverse
cosine of X so what is so our goal here
is to figure out I want the derivative
with respect to X of the inverse cosine
inverse cosine of X what is this going
to be equal to so assuming you've had a
go at it let's work through it so just
like last time we could write let's just
just set Y being equal to this Y is
equal D inverse cosine of X which means
the same thing is saying that X is equal
to the cosine cosine of Y now let's take
the derivative of both sides with
respect to X on the left hand side
you're just going to have a 1 we're just
going to have a 1 and on the right hand
side you're going to have the derivative
of cosine Y with respect to Y which is
negative sine of Y times the derivative
of Y with respect to X which is DS dy/dx
and so we get if we let's see if we
divide both sides by negative sine of Y
we get dy/dx is equal to negative 1 over
sine of Y now like we've seen before
this is kind of satisfying but we have
our derivative in terms of Y we want it
in terms of X and we know that X is
cosine of Y so let's see if we can
rewrite this bottom expression in terms
of cosine of Y said of sine of Y well we
know when we saw in the last video that
from the Pythagorean identity that that
cosine squared of Y plus sine squared of
Y is equal to 1 we know that sine of Y
is equal to the square root of 1 minus
cosine squared of Y so this is equal to
negative 1 this is just a manipulation
of the Pythagorean trig identity this is
equal to 1 minus cosine and I could
write like this cosine squared of Y but
I'll write it
like this because it'll make it a little
bit clearer and what is cosine of Y well
of course that is X so this is equal to
negative 1 over the square root of 1
minus instead of writing cosine y
instead of writing cosine Y you're
trying to switch colors instead of
writing cosine Y we could write 1 minus
X 1 minus x squared so there you have it
the derivative with respect to X of the
inverse cosine of X is is well I think I
lost that color I'll do it in magenta is
equal to 1 is equal to negative 1 over
the square root of 1 minus x squared so
this is a neat thing this right over
here is a neat thing to know and of
course we should compare it to the
inverse the in the derivative of the
inverse sine actually let me put them
side by side and we see that the only
difference here is is the sine so let me
copy and paste that so copy and paste it
I'm going to paste it down here and now
let's look at them side by side so we
see for taking the derivative with
respect to X of the inverse cosine
function we have a negative of a
negative 1 over the square root of 1
minus x squared if you're looking at the
derivative with respect to X of the
inverse sine it's the same expression
except now it is positive